foreign
I want to talk about what unfolded with
Scott Adams this week and we have of
course talked about Scott Adams in
recent podcasts and this is for I want
to talk about this for a totally
different reason this has nothing to do
with our ongoing uh
disagreement with Scott about why it is
that we were right about covet right he
thinks it was lucky guesses we think
it's models
um and by the way we're right but in any
case put that aside Scott Adams became
big news again this week because he said
something rather remarkable on his own
daily podcast
um Zach do you want to show it yep yep
I've accidentally joined the hey group
so if if you know nearly half of All
Blacks are not okay with white people
according to this poll not according to
me
according to this poll
that's a hate group
and I don't want to have anything to do
with them
and I would say you know based on the
current way things are going the best
advice I would give to white people is
to get the hell away from black people
just get the away
wherever you have to go just get away
because there's no fixing this
okay now
um I want us to put aside our initial
reaction to the content of what he says
it's very shocking right he's
effectively arguing for a kind of
um segregation self-segregation by race
and he's doing so on the basis of a poll
a Rasmussen poll
and
what I want to resist doing it's very
easy to take podcasts at him after he
says something like this but I really
want to pursue this a little bit deeper
because it has a deeper implication
um
the poll in question reports that
something under 50 but not weigh under
50 percent
of black people
say uh do not resonate with the
statement that it is okay to be white
but that that's that's the thing yeah do
not resonate with the statement they do
not agree that it is okay to be white
47 with uh 95 confidence that it's
within three points
um the same poll
also asked whether or not
um but so people who aren't white are
being asked
is it okay to be white yes not is it oh
I'm confused
well I mean it is a confusing moment
that such a question would make any
freaking sense is
um
yeah I mean like sure at one level it's
like okay with a pool if you is it okay
to be human like I don't what I am
and right like so is it okay to be an
Earthling
what yeah but right but oh my God but I
don't so I don't get what was this uh
was this a poll that was sort of across
all Americans and then they also took
data on race and then and yep it was a
tiny little bowl a thousand people
um total yeah of which some fraction of
that were black people yep and almost
half of them said uh I do not agree with
the statement it is okay to be white
correct now the same poll okay uh asked
um
oh can black people be racist and 79
uh agreed that black people can be
racist 79 of the entire pool or of black
people I believe 79 of black people I
would have to go back and look carefully
but nonetheless this is a tiny poll okay
a tiny pole and with a suspect
methodology very easy to screw up a poll
that is a combination of a phone pole
and a online survey right so not a huge
study
sounds total garbage yeah total garbage
but nonetheless it's 2023 right somehow
we have landed in a place where the
question of whether or not it is okay to
be white is somehow not laughable on its
face
um so that is an interesting fact well I
mean so this is going to seem totally
far afield but like I'm not I cannot see
this I'm not familiar with this
obviously I don't know anything about
the poll but the idea that like okay the
methods are garbage and the question
being asked is garbage as well that like
that sounds like where have we seen that
before like that sounds like medical
research and scientific research like oh
not only is the question you asked
nonsensical in the context of the
environment in which we are living but
also your methods had absolutely no way
of determining whether or not uh
absolutely no way of answering the
question right well let's just point to
one obvious bias here okay the survey
will obviously be biased in the
direction of those who are more likely
to voice an opinion right and so it may
be that opinionated people are heavily
biased in the direction of having an
extreme view for example and that this
doesn't in any way represent the sum
total most people uh might just think
well yeah of course why would I you know
why would I what is that question yeah
what does that question even mean so but
the reason that I raise it
there is a
podcast that I did at the very beginning
of Dark Horse long before the live
streams I believe uh in which I
pointed out
that one of the hazards of the
um woke emphasis on race and the
demonizing of the concept of what they
call whiteness was that it was going to
drive white people together and that
that was going to be a disaster not only
for everybody but especially for people
who aren't white that this was going to
effectively take this potentially
powerful you know lineage or pseudo
lineage
and it was going to inflame it and cause
it to gather and because it's a majority
uh you know compared to any compared to
the next largest lineage in the US at
least that that was going to be an
extremely dangerous thing to do so it
was uh it was a warning from me saying
don't do this this is gum especially if
your concern is the well-being of people
who uh are from Minority populations you
are creating the very coalitions that
you would have us believe are the most
dangerous coalitions that exist right
and Scott Adams is giving voice to the
thing that will cause people to gather
what he says in this clip is literally
look if people aren't okay with white
folks then I suggest white folks get
away from them now he screws up
a what he said and he should recognize
it is deeply un-American
it is deeply Un-American that we should
be getting away from some population
because among the many special things
about this country
um perhaps the most special is the
experiment in which we attempt to put
aside lineage level considerations and
to live together as a collaborative
people right and so what he's saying oh
I just want to get away from those
people if they're not cool with me is
exactly the opposite of what his
response should be
as a patriotic American his point should
be holy hell if that's real
what can we do about it right I would
also point out that even if the poll is
accurate as they did it like let's just
say that none of the methodological
methodological considerations end up
being important and that it is somehow
representative
well it still means that a majority of
black people do think it's okay to be
white and so the idea that the right
reaction to a large minority of any
group uh coming to this also deeply
Un-American conclusion is to abandon the
entire population and go isolating your
own racial group is insane right the
point is this isn't all hands on deck
moment right we need to confront the
woke ideology that is attempting to
demonize so-called whiteness and we need
to confront this instinct to well if
that's what you're going to do then
we're going to X right
there's
we are such a confused people
um
there are
immutable characteristics
sex is one of them
your ancestry is one of them and that
Maps very imperfectly onto sort of
public Renditions of what race you are
right no one is pure
anything almost right like actually I'll
just like no one is pure anything
there's no pure Bloods right like that's
that's an that's an insanity but there
are you know there are people who are
more Lithuanian than anything else and
people who are more you know African
origin than anything else who are in
America and therefore are
African-Americans you know this this is
this is true and this cannot change
like you are you are what your history
was and you are what you know if you're
a mammal uh the sperm that contributed
half of its gen half of what is now your
genetic complement to making you who you
are determined whether you are male or
female
and those things don't change and so the
idea that we
could be talking about whether it's okay
to be something that you're born as
we live in the age of original sin like
what what is this what what kind of
garbage is this and then at the same
time you've got you know apropower
conversation last week
people saying well you know people are
just born with these predilections that
are like
horrible like pedophilia like what can
you do you just got to accept them you
can't shame them for you know having
these having these feelings that they
have you know there's there's nothing to
be done about it's like you know what
that thing
not foundational not fundamental not
about your lineage and also a hazard to
guess not immutable so so no we don't
you know we don't use shame we would
never advocate for shame around
something that
you are you are born with it is
something it is fundamental to who you
are
and instead we've got we've flipped
these things we're shaming people for
their lineage
we're pretending they can change the sex
that they are
and we're embracing people's Kinks which
are fundamentally bad for society
one two three wrong wrong wrong like how
do we get here
you know who has a really good model
that helps sort this out
we do here get that book this book yeah
that book yeah okay yeah so in in this
book yeah we talk about the distinction
between the software layer and the
hardware layer and you may or may not
love that distinction I happen to think
it's super uh elegant and that the fact
that it works even when you start to
pursue it well what about the firmware
level yeah we got that too
um you know the point is we do function
this way and we humans
are the extreme case of a creature with
dual inheritance right we inherit the
genetic stuff which as you point out you
can't do anything about it you know it's
whatever happens to come together
between sperm and egg and then we get a
software package loaded on you know are
we a blank slate no but well but that's
to
I I think in part people get confused
because the software Hardware analogy
isn't perfect because the software is is
the mutable part the fungible part the
plastic part right the software
um from you know day one is in is
beginning to be informed by the
environment well I guess on day one
you're still up maybe in the Fallopian
tubes I don't remember exactly the
timing but call it you know day 14 of of
a zygote and the uterine environment is
affecting how development happens and
you know there's there's a reason that
morning sicknesses morning sickness and
aversions and Cravings during pregnancy
are what they are and that's the zygotes
and then the fetus's way of
communicating to Mom hey I need more of
this or like no not that that's gonna
hurt me right so that you know that that
is all the developing software and so
unlike
Microsoft Word right where you bring it
in and you can say oh well I you know I
actually want to see this in my ribbon
and this in my toolbar
um we we are changing much more about
what we are yeah but I mean we don't
need to get tied up in this but my point
would be all you got to do is then say
well how good an analogy is that and
then pursue it into the computer layer
and you find out well the same thing is
true there not identically so but you
know the the software that gets loaded
onto the underlying computer by the
manufacturer before you get around to
deciding what software you want to put
onto the thing the point is it it's
there and you've got an underlying
Hardware layer that is uh
predisposed to emerge through genes
about which you can do nothing and then
you've got every layer of flexibility in
the software layer from not much
flexibility at all up through perfectly
flexible
and it all it all works but anyway
you're right the point is we've reverse
the order we're now shaming people for
the stuff that they can't change and we
are refusing to shame them for the stuff
that they really must change and that is
an indicative of something it is
indicative of the fact that these
conclusions are not based on some deep
model of reality what they are is about
power
right it is very powerful to take
something that somebody cannot change
and decide that it is a reason to shun
them right because the point is they
can't you know show up one day and say
well I've dealt with it deal with me
it's like no you're still White
you still suck you know you are
obligated to spend all your time getting
over your whiteness and you know what
it's never going to work so go away and
work on that project and get back to me
at the point that uh well you can't
because it's unfixable except uh the the
ideology comes to uh
somehow an equally absurd but almost
opposite conclusion over in sex space
right oh you can cure the problem of
having been born male because how dare
you by putting on lipstick and heels and
asking to be called Martha
what did you just do and why
what on Earth are half-ish of the
country doing going along with it
nodding going like yeah yeah you you go
girl
what what is happening right no it it's
absurd and you know I don't know how
many times we're going to see this
pattern right it's one thing to not
understand anything and to have a random
response it's another thing to invert
reality yeah and to take the immutable
and treat it as perfectly plastic and to
take the perfectly plastic and treat it
as a mutable
you know that's not just wrong it's
upside down of right you know and it's
upside down of right and I think to get
back to
you know this question of like oh well
will the hate campaign that's
masquerading as loving tenderness and
book ideology
um cause segregation which in turn will
cause ever greater division
um yeah yeah it will and
and is it
better for us to be interested in
hanging out with people who aren't
exactly like us yes
are we obliged to do that all the time
no are we in fact obliged to do whatever
no
but uh do we find our worlds enhanced
and better in every regard when we do
yes this holds for sex for race for
religion for politics for level of
education for trade for you know career
for you know basically across the board
right so does that mean that you should
never ever ever hang out with people
like you like you shouldn't go to a
conference for biologists or hang out in
an all-women space or
have a friend group that is all black
and sometimes say you know what it's us
going to be here today and love you but
like not you today it's going to be us
that's all good too yep right like we we
actually can have that both ways we can
know that it's better to as a life
choice be embracing of actual difference
like actual diversity be inclusive of
actual diversity while also allowing for
people to make individual choices that
hopefully don't make art this sum of all
of their choices in which they say right
now because I need to learn more
accounting I'm going to go hang out with
the accountants and right now because
this is where my headspace is right now
you know you're going to go hang out
with a bunch of men and right now you
know I'm gonna hang out with a bunch of
you know ukrainians you know whatever it
is right like that's also okay you can
you can have it you can't have this both
ways and somehow we're being told
any choice that we make if we have
certain immutable characteristics is is
inherently wrong and uh and and we have
to go along with the fantasies of crazy
people yeah
um
I would also point out that those who
are most likely to just simply narrowly
take Scott Adams to task for his uh
an American Outburst uh
are also likely to be people who have
caused the problem this is why I
delivered that warning all that years
ago all those years ago that if you do
this if you demonize people over their
race whether that race is understood to
be a privileged one or not you are going
to reinvent this problem which we had
not solved but we were definitely on our
way to solving it yeah the West had
understood correctly that the right
thing to be is a colorblind Society
colorblind not meaning that we don't
notice each other's color it means that
it is not an indicator of your
likelihood of success it does not it
does not predispose you to succeed in a
court of law or a classroom or anything
it's just a simple fact like your hair
color or your language of
of your birth now I'm going to take one
objection there because I do think
but some of the language that we use uh
easily is maybe contributing to
conclusion to the confusion which is
that in this case we hadn't solved it
what I will tend to say is but we were
moving in the right direction and I I
really honestly believe that that we're
moving pretty fast in the right
direction we were it was getting ever
better
um but I would say not I think what you
said was
um
we might have solved it or we could have
solved it or something like that and and
I and I know that you don't think that
there's a static solution to be had and
you know maybe it's an asymptote but
even if it's an asymptote that asymptote
itself will move because you know people
are people are going to people no no no
no no no I don't I don't agree with this
the asymptote is the line of formal
colorblindness of your Society you're
allowed to be any color it's allowed to
have its implications but in some
individuals are gonna gonna not buy in
well but the point is the asymptote is
the degree to which everybody is on
board with the idea that your color
ought not predispose you to succeed in
any context it's just a simple fact of
who you are it's not um it's not a
predictive fact on the basis that you
have advantages coming from One race or
another so anyway the asymptote is US
collectively by reaching a place where
you know you know basically the
asymptote is uh Martin Luther King Jr's
uh I have a dream right it is you are
judged on the content of your character
and not the color of your skin
and you know the degree to which we are
at the or approaching the asymptote is
the degree to which everybody's on board
with that
[Music]
thank you